considera la siguiente curva de densidad
aquí vemos esta curva de densidad que
describe la distribución de probabilidad
de una variable aleatoria continua esta
variable aleatoria continua puede tomar
valores que van desde 1 hasta 5 y tienen
la misma probabilidad de tomar
cualquiera de estos valores entre 1 y 5
encuentra la probabilidad de que x sea
menor que 4 x va de 1 a 4
no existe la probabilidad de que sea
menor que 1 y sabemos que toda el área
bajo la curva de densidad es igual a 1
si podemos encontrar la fracción del
área que coincide con nuestra
restricción podremos responder la
pregunta el área que nos interesa va de
1 a 4 y la razón por la que se comienza
en 1 es porque no hay probabilidad
alguna de que esta variable pueda tener
un valor menor que 1 podemos verlo en la
curva de densidad nos interesa conocer
cuál es el área de aquí es un rectángulo
cuya altura es 0.25 y cuya base es 1/2
el área es 0.25 por 3 que nos da 0.75
así que la probabilidad de que x sea
menor que 4 es 0.75 o una probabilidad
del 75% hagamos otro problema con una
curva de densidad un poco más
sofisticada el conjunto de medidas de
las alturas de un grupo de estudiantes
de secundaria tiene una distribución
normal una media de 150 centímetros y
una desviación estándar de 20
centímetros h es la altura de un
estudiante elegido aleatoriamente
encuentra e interpreta la probabilidad
de que la variable h la altura de un
estudiante elegido aleatoriamente sea
mayor que 170 centímetros visualicemos
primero la curva de densidad es una
distribución normal nos dicen que la
media es 150 centímetros la dibujamos y
también nos dicen que tiene una
desviación estándar de 20 centímetros la
desviación estándar por arriba de la
media es 170 y la desviación estándar
debajo de la media es 130 centímetros y
si elegimos aleatoriamente la altura de
uno de estos estudiantes y queremos
saber cuál es la probabilidad de que la
altura sea mayor que 170 va a ser esta
área bajo la curva de la distribución
normal cómo podemos calcularla hay
varias formas en las que podemos hacer
esto sabemos que esta es el área por
arriba de una desviación estándar por
encima de la media
podemos usar una tabla zeta o podemos
usar el conocimiento general que se
tiene sobre las distribuciones normales
el área que se encuentra una desviación
estándar por debajo de la media y una
desviación estándar por arriba de la
media es decir esta área de aquí es
aproximadamente 68% que es cercana a 60
y 8.2 por ciento pero para nuestros
propósitos está bien que usemos 68% del
área a partir de la media y una
desviación estándar por arriba de ella
será la mitad de eso esto es
aproximadamente 34 por ciento también
sabemos que para una distribución normal
el área por debajo de la media será de
50 por ciento lo que estamos señalando
aquí así que el área combinada que se
encuentra por debajo de 170 o debajo de
una desviación estándar por arriba de la
media será aproximadamente de 84 % esto
nos ayuda a encontrar el área por arriba
de una desviación estándar por arriba de
la media que será la respuesta a nuestra
pregunta toda el área bajo esta curva de
densidad y bajo cualquier curva de
densidad va a ser igual a 1 así que toda
esta área es 1 esta área de aquí es 84 %
1.84 restamos 1 a esto y nos queda el
área que nos interesa
1 - 0.84 aproximadamente lo que nos da
aproximadamente punto 16 si quisieran
usar un valor un poco más preciso pueden
usar una tabla acepta el área por debajo
de una desviación estándar
arriba de la media será cercana a 84
puntos 1 % lo que nos dará esta
respuesta como 0.159 que se acerca a
0.16 pero pueden ver que nos acercamos
bastante a esta respuesta al conocer la
regla general de que el área entre una
desviación estándar por arriba de la
media y una desviación estándar por
debajo de la media es aproximadamente
68% para una distribución normal